hello i think i i think i almost died
last night really
yeah actually okay i want to know
if anyone is if anyone knows anything
about electricity
about wattage about amps
about jewels i don't know what other uh
units electricity is measured in
oh um
uh amber and i already said
watts um [ __ ] um
vibes yeah vibes that's a form of
electricity yeah
yeah like sort of chemistry like the
electricity you're giving me it's like
the vibes really yeah you almost die
though
so i i was um i was in bed and i
was wearing my necklace okay and i took
it off
and i dropped it and it landed on top of
my power bar
that like my uh phone charger is plugged
into okay and i think one of the ends
went in one of the holes
and the other end was touching another
like the other side of
of the phone charger or something like
that because when i picked it up it
blew up like a [ __ ] giant spark it
exploded pretty much
and i like fell back i think if i was
touching the ground maybe i would have
like died
because i was on my bed so i wasn't
grounded i like i'm just
honestly just trying to try to uh
you know um like
collect my seventh grade uh knowledge
about electricity and circuits and stuff
like that
yeah so any scientists in the chat let
us know
if cody almost died um and then
afterwards i look down i look at my
necklace and it's blown in half
the phone charger is all black on it
i feel like i almost died i mean you
definitely
yeah yeah yeah
that's um that's easily like you know
you could put that like in a song or
something you think i'm saying
like yeah yeah like like dwp came to get
me
i'm saying like dwp just tried to kill
you bro
like we what we should do is stop this
podcast and realize and figure out how
we're going to get them back because
not only did they [ __ ] snatch your
chain but they almost killed you
are we beefing now with dwp or b with
dwp ddwp snatched my boy's chain
that's what they did they didn't even
snatch it they just blew it up they blew
up my voice which isn't
which is even worse of a move could you
imagine just ruining someone's jewelry
not even stealing it
yeah i mean how how could you like i
look i i always
look at you know rappers and they have
like crazy chains like that
and i just think man it takes a certain
level of not give a [ __ ] to just have
that in a restaurant and just even eat
like spaghetti or something
yeah you know and yeah to not have like
a bodyguard around you at all times
that and just to not care it's like oh a
little hot dog grease
whatever on oops on my hundred thousand
dollar chain yeah
oh just wearing a mortgage oops just
wearing a down payment for a house so
yeah oh that's somebody's whole salary
maybe a hard ass chain a chain with a
pendant that says down payment
yeah or your salary or your salary
your rent
[Laughter]
so mean
that's great just like specialized
chains per interview
like hey man i went and got this chain
for you and it says like academics rent
it's like what
like yeah i talked to conflicts i
figured out how much money you make
yeah i put it right here just so you
could know i talked to complex and then
i talked to your landlord
yeah figured out what your annual rent
would be this isn't monthly this is
annual we're talking 12 months
your annual rent and annual rent
here's the thing though bro it's so it
was so small that i couldn't spell out
your annual so i had to upgrade to
your your 10-year rent period
you don't even like pay enough rent to
give me a chain do you understand how
rich i am
this is actually i so i actually
calculated what this would be in ten
years if you deposited now
and compounded five percent interest
over ten years this is what your salary
this is what your salary now is gonna is
going
to be when you're 50 years old
[Laughter]
can you just sit in there like oh
so um yeah the new album
has the baby on it and
oh wow that's like all 10 years really
right there right there in your neck
yep yep 10 years of salary all invested
damn so literally this is also if you
don't even spend any so you can't go on
vacation
oh oh wow yeah
so that's so cool man um
[Laughter]
so yeah track three you got halsey
that's like um
yeah halsey yeah yeah that's the track
called health insurance because we have
it
oh a ton of it way more than i can use
you got a chain that covers my copay
because
that would really hurt me
i mean bro that's i mean that's like not
what not to bring
up last week but that's what i said on
stream about [ __ ]
after i got my eye exam yeah i like got
done and i'm like i feel better and then
it cost me half a playstation and i was
like what the [ __ ] is this
oh did it yeah it was like 300 bucks
just to get my what
yeah it was crazy jesus christ i mean
like i don't you know
i think uh i think it's because i don't
really have like
good eye coverage because i mean i don't
think i have any
and mine is like a hundred and 150 or
something dude
i'm we go on tour people are going to be
like trying to infect our eyes and [ __ ]
our eyes aren't insured jabbing them out
just a uv laser light oh what's up boys
are a laser pointer all the way from the
back row
[Music]
yeah i just blinded them on stage and
you meant like in the meet and greets
people are going to be trying
to yeah yeah yo what's up good to meet
you cool good to meet you
a kid has an eye patch and he lifts it
up and it's just like a [ __ ] uv laser
gun underneath that [ __ ] he's like
surprised